pourquoi les meilleurs sont ils les
meilleurs avez vous remarqué que les
meilleurs élèves ont plus souvent
l'occasion de s'améliorer que les moins
bons par exemple on donnera plus souvent
la parole à un élève qui s'expriment le
mieux dans une langue étrangère lui
permettant de ce fait de progresser un
peu plus à chaque prise de parole
avez vous remarqué que les meilleurs
sportifs ont l'occasion d'intégrer les
meilleures structures qui leur
permettent de progresser
avez vous remarqué que les personnes
riches ont plus d'occasions d'augmenter
leurs richesses que les personnes
pauvres qui de ce fait le resteront je
me rends sur youtube où l'on met à celui
du campement où naîtront même succulent
robert merton sociologue américain a
publié dans la revue science en 1968 un
article dans lequel il explique un
phénomène davantage cumulatif qu'il
observe dans le champ scientifique
il appelle ce processus les faits
matures en référence au verset biblique
de l'évangile de saint matthieu
dans cette vidéo je vous présente les
faits mathieu dans les sciences telles
que la formule et robert merton robert
merton explique dans cet article qu'au
niveau des récompenses scientifiques se
sont pas toujours les plus méritants qui
obtiennent la reconnaissance
il existe des mécanismes psychosociaux
qui biaise le processus de récompenses
qui influe ensuite sur les systèmes de
communication de la science et met en
place une sélection sociale
merton se base principalement sur des
entretiens réalisés par son épouse
également sociologue harriet superman
celle ci dans le cadre de ses recherches
sur les avantages cumulatif à rencontrer
différents lauréats de prix nobel aux
états unis que cela soit en physique ou
en médecine les interviews montre que
les scientifiques célèbre jouissent d'un
crédit disproportionnée pour leurs
contributions scientifiques
tandis que les scientifiques
relativement inconnus ont
proportionnellement très peu de crédit
pour des contributions comparables cela
peut particulièrement bien ceux observés
dans les travaux collectifs où le
scientifique le plus retenu se verra
attribuer la plus grande partie des
mérites
même si son rôle a été mineur dans la co
écriture de la recherche les découverts
simultanée et indépendantes sont
porteuses d'un mécanisme similaire
des chercheurs font la même découverte
moment de manière totalement
indépendante et c'est généralement le
scientifique le plus renommé qui se
verra gratifier de la découverte ce
processus nuit aux chercheurs novice
dont les travaux manque de visibilité
éclipsé par ceux des grands noms de la
discipline
toutefois les travaux collectifs peuvent
devenir des atouts pour le scientifique
débutants celui qui a été associé à des
scientifiques importants et qu'ils
persévèrent à produire des travaux de
qualité peut voir ses travaux passés
reconnu rétroactivement et valoriser
d'autant plus que des grands noms y
étaient associés dans ce cas la
reconnaissance et simplement aux pauses
et déplacés dans le temps merton
constate dans les témoignages et un
effet de compensation est bien présent
dans le système de récompense les
travaux d'un scientifique sont
sous-évalués au début de sa carrière
tandis que ses travaux ultérieurs sont
surestimés cette réalité colle
particulièrement bien à ce verset de
l'évangile de saint matthieu puisque
ceux qui ont auront encore plus et ceux
qui n'ont presque rien qui débute auront
encore moi ce mécanisme inéquitable et
parfois pris en considération par les
scientifiques eux-mêmes qui voit une
double injustice dans l'attribution des
mérites donne entre oppose un et pas
assez aux autres certains scientifiques
reconnus refuse même la coécriture de
certaines publications à fans à faire de
l'ombre à leurs jeunes collègues
ce dysfonctionnement dans le système de
récompense a des répercussions dans le
système de communication du monde
scientifique le phénomène influence non
seulement les carrières mais aussi la
visibilité des contributions de chacun
les publications des scientifiques
renommés ont meilleure publicité que
celle de ceux qui n'ont pas encore été
reconnu
de cette manière le fait qu'un grand nom
s'associe à un novice peut apporter une
visibilité et donc une possibilité de
reconnaissance des travaux de ce dernier
merton insiste sur le fait que pour
autant que l'effet mathieu soit
dysfonctionnelle pour le système de
récompense
il est fonctionnel dans le système de
communication c'est à dire qu'il permet
un tri de l'information cela est
d'autant plus important est dans le
champ scientifique très peu de
publications sont lus par les
scientifiques eux mêmes
on parle par exemple de -2 1% au chimie
ou en psychologie
les sociologues stephen johnattan tôles
ont calculé un indice de visibilité des
publications scientifiques et ils ont en
effet constaté que plus
le rang d'un scientifique est élevé plus
ces travaux sont diffusés dans la
communauté scientifique les prix nobel
obtiennent par exemple un score de 85
alors que les physiciens jamais
récompensé obtiennent une note de
visibilité de 17
et à chaque nouvelle récompense la
visibilité d'un scientifique et est
renforcée merten insinue à ce titre que
l'explosion du nombre de publications
encourage les faits mathieu dans cette
fonction de mise en lumière de certaines
publications permettant à chacun
finalement de savoir où porter son
attention autrement dit dans un contexte
de concurrence et de profusion des
travaux l'effet mathieu permet aux
scientifiques d'identifier plus
facilement les publications qui pourront
se révéler être déterminant dans leur
domaine
l'effet mathieu est donc un mécanisme
important pour la science en effet la
science est une démarche collective où
les connaissances sont produites sur
base des contributions multiples et des
travaux réalisés par d'autres la
communication et les échanges entre les
scientifiques sont donc primordiaux
l'effet mathieu par la curation des
contenus qu'il permet et de ce fait un
mécanisme qui permet à la science de se
développer en tant que construction
sociale merton va encore plus loin il
dit que la visibilité des travaux des
grands noms d'une discipline n'est pas
seulement due à un effet de halo il veut
dire par là que le seul prestige social
des hommes de science n'est pas la seule
cause du crédit accordé aux travaux
scientifiques
il ya également des causes
psychologiques et sociales qui sont en
jeu les grands noms ont également
intégré par socialisation auprès de leur
mentor certaines attitudes des valeurs
qui les destine à produire des travaux
significatifs et déterminant pour leur
discipline
merton dit que les grands noms dégage un
charisme qui n'est que la traduction de
certaines normes et valeurs celles ci
correspondent à un développement du sens
du pouls à l'acquisition de certains
schémas de pensée et de langage
un culte de l'effort qui les portent
vers des enjeux fondamentaux et non les
questions périphériques et secondaire de
leur domaine d'études parce qu'ils ont
une certaine représentation de leur
métier de leurs travaux les grands
scientifiques sont dotés d'une volonté
d'une confiance en lui sans faille qui
leur permet à la fois de surmonter les
difficultés de tout ordre mais aussi de
persévérer a trouvé la découverte
déterminante est fondamental dans leur
discipline ils n'hésitent donc pas à
refuser des recherches hasardeuse qui
n'ont que peu de chances d'aboutir sur
des découvertes majeures
ils affrontent les critiques qui ciblent
leur pro
destination parce qu'ils veulent être
déterminant et c'est parce qu'ils ont
été formés aux côtés de grands noms ils
deviennent eux mêmes des scientifiques
de premier plan une grande majorité des
lauréats au prix nobel ont travaillé
plus jeunes pour des prix nobel qui ont
ainsi assuré leur socialisation et leur
future reconnaissance l'effet mathieu et
en plus un cas particulier de prophétie
auto réalisatrice qui pour rappel est un
énoncé fo qui devient vrai par le seul
fait qu'il soit énoncée par exemple
médias annoncent une pénurie peu
probable de papier toilette
cette pénurie se réalise uniquement
parce que les auditeurs ou entendu
l'information et se sont rués dans les
magasins de peur de manquer de papier
toilette et donc ont provoqué une
rupture prophétie auto réalisatrice
de la même manière parce qu'ils sont
annoncés comme de grands noms l'effet
mathieu poussé scientifiques de renom à
assurer des publications de qualité
d'une part et d'autre part la
publication de ces travaux est attendu
par le public qui accordera du temps et
de l'énergie pour lire ses travaux et y
déceler toute la profondeur du travail
accompli un tel crédit une telle
attention n'aurait sans doute pas été
accordées à des travaux - entendus et
aurait donc empêché d'y découvrir
certaines pépites et donc de les
reconnaître comme déterminant pour la
science et on retrouve ici un
dysfonctionnement puisque l'effet
mathieu empêche la prise en
considération de découvertes importantes
mais réalisée par des inconnus pour
terminer on peut parler des effets
institutionnels et de sélection sociale
de l'effet mathieu obéissant au principe
énoncé tout au long de cette vidéo qui
fait qu'on ne donne qu'aux riches
les grandes universités auront tendance
à recruter les scientifiques les plus
réputés ces universités deviendront des
pôles concentrant toutes les ressources
intellectuelles tandis que des
universités de second ordre seront sans
cesse pillés de leurs meilleurs éléments
au parallèle les moyens matériels et
financiers seront plus facilement
accordées aux grandes universités du
fait de la réputation de leur ment ceux
ci auront donc plus de facilité à
réaliser de grandes découvertes que
leurs collègues issus des universités de
second plan entretenant ce mécanisme
davantage cumulatif qu'elle ait fait
mature cette publication montre bien que
le travail de merton s'inscrit dans le
paradigme fonctionnaliste car elle
appréhende la réalité sous l'angle de
fonctions remplies par les faits mathieu
et de dysfonctionnements auxquels il
conduit en tant que prof de sciences
sociales je trouve que l'effet mathieu
est un mécanisme psychologique sociale
et institutionnelle
un utile pour comprendre bon nombre de
phénomènes tels que certaines inégalités
scolaires ou sociale cette vidéo est
terminée abonnez vous si vous l'avez
apprécié n'oubliez pas de consulter le
descriptif où vous trouverez l'article
original de merton ainsi qu'une
traduction offerte par ma chère épouse
et je vous met également le lien faire
un résumé de l'article réalisés par les
élèves de 5e année sciences sociales du
collège visitation la dernière merci
donc à sophie née annan liam alexandra
élise et luan emilie et killian pour ce
travail et je vous dis à très bientôt
dans deux nouvelles vidéos consacrés aux
sciences sociales
[Musique]